اطلقت شركه اتصالات ضمن مشاركتها بمرض
جايتكس لهذا العام باماره دبي مجموعه من
الحلول الذكيه ركزت على توفير التكنولوجيا
وتوسيع الخيارات امام المستخدمين للتحكم
بمنازلهم بشتى المجالات بدءا من الناحيه
الامنيه ووصولا الى التحكم بمعدل استهلاك
الطاقه وعندي ثلاث باقات اللي هي باقه
السيف هوم اللي هو البيت الامن فيها سموك
ديكتر هذه اذا لا قدر الله في حريق او شيء
وبيعطي الارم للجهات المعنيه فيها كاميرات
للمراقبه فلاد ديتكشن اذا سبحان الله صار
في ليكج للماي او شيء في البيت اجهزه تحسس
للحركه المومنت فاذا انا مش في البيت
موجود اذا صارت في حركه او شي بيبعث الام
كول هوم هذه الباكج الثاني اللي هي فيها
تتحكم بالتكييف طبعا او المكييفات في
المنزل من الموبايل فاق اشوف مثلا اذا
عيالي بغرفه معينه مش موجودين في الغرفه
بس مشغلين مكيف ورايحين يعني فهذه بتساعد
كلها من منظومه المدينه الذكيه المنزل
الذكي وشملت مشاركه اتصالات ما هو ابعد من
اطار المنزل اذ وفرت حلولا ذكيه لمحبي
النشاطات الرياضيه في نظارات ذكيه هذه
النظاره طبعا للرياضه وانا اجري مثلا
تعطيني معلومات عن سرعتي عن دقات القلب عن
الجو في اشياء تساعدني انا في اثناء
الرياضه في طبعا الاكستريم سبورتس طبعا
الدراجات وما شاء الله احنا
عننا بالامارات وخليج يعني نحب الدراجات
والاور اتي في هلمت ذكيه الحين الهلمت
الذكي طبعا في اجهزه استشعار اذا صار لا
قدر الله حادث او شي يبعث ورنين لجهات
المعنيه انه صار في حادث او للمدرب مثلا
للكوتش في سمارت جوجل هذه بعد للرياضه
للسبورت للدراجات فيها بون ديسبلاي داخل
الجوجل يفرجيني معلومات اللي انا بالنسبه
لي بتكون مهمه بدون ما انا اطلع مثلا اشوف
الموبايل لاني انا على دراجه مثلا ايضا
سويتر ذكي يعني البس فانيلا ذكيه الفانيلا
فيها اجهزه استشعار تستشعر دقات القلب ضغط
الدم مستوى التعرق وفي جوارب ذكيه سوكس
يعني هذه مش بس بيقوللي انت قاعد تركض
بهالسرعه لا تخبرني مثلا هل انا قاعد احط
وزني مناسب مثلا بالامام بالخلف هل هي
الجري صحي او
لا